old city in the Amazon mr. Mendez but
job death I didn't have Northwestern
Brazil on the earth deep in the Amazon
in December of 1988 the fate of the
rainforest was changed by a murder in
the small town of Sheppard II Chico
Mendes was shot and killed
serving Brazil's
irreplaceable rainfalls and he paid for
that apparently with his life two armed
guards have been hired to protect him
but they were inside his house when she
Co was hit by a bullet in his backyard
Chico had led the fight to protect the
largest rainforest on the planet it was
a fight that alerted the world to the
exploitation of the Amazon and changed
the makeup of the rainforest for decades
to come
[Music]
the Amazon basin is rich in rubber trees
that produce latex and for a long time
they were exclusive to this rainforest
native people had collected latex or
liquid rubber for centuries but in the
late 1800s
after the Europeans turned their
attention to it people started
extracting latex on a mass scale it
became a valuable material and rapidly
industrializing nations where motorcars
with rubber tires started hitting the
roads the Amazon quickly turned into a
very profitable global resource
especially in Brazil where businessmen
started moving into the rainforest to
keep up with the high demand wealthy
rubber barons forced indigenous people
to work for them as rubber stoppers and
they directed waves of migrants from the
coast to the rainforest River Stoppers
were forced to work in exchange for the
use of the land tools or food so the
more they worked the more they were in
debt to their bosses but the rubber boom
wouldn't last long in the 1870s an
English colonist smuggled 70,000 rubber
tree seeds out of the Amazon the seeds
went from Brazil to British colonies in
Southeast Asia where they began
harvesting rubber at a lower cost over
the years as rubber from these
plantations flooded the market prices
fell and the rubber boom in the Amazon
collapsed but demand spiked again during
the Second World War when rubber became
critical to making weapons and vehicles
and that rubber to fill the tank and not
rubber to win the war the Brazilian
government recruited tens of thousands
and forced them to extract latex under
harsh conditions after the war demand
collapsed again and most rubber barons
moved on to other businesses leaving
many rubber tappers in the rainforest
where they settled and were now free to
harvest rubber on their own terms
among them was Chico Mendes a young
rubber tapper who started out working
under rubber bosses who shook Willy
Billy Dodd the assembly the aerials
Kesey on Jesus a son really preposterous
tratado we sitting this is Raimundo
Mendez de barros Chico's cousin who
works and lives on a reserve and Hawker
estate I knew who she was time to step
in and lead but come in the 70s and 80s
when the Amazon began seeing
deforestation at an unprecedented rate
Chico Mendes and the rubber stoppers
lived freely in the state of aquifers
out a decade they harvested rubber and
collected Brazil nuts sustainably
without damaging the forests and made a
living selling what they gathered two
traveling merchants but there was a
problem on the horizon at the time
Brazil was led by a military regime that
wanted to use the Amazon for economic
development so they opened it up to
ranchers for business they took over
large estates typically occupied by
rubber stoppers and cleared the forest
to make room for their cattle the
politics of land speculation and the
large-scale deforestation that have as
their objectives the substitution of man
by cattle it would be a disaster if this
process were allowed to continue in our
region the ranchers used intimidation
tactics to expel rubber tubber's they
hired gunmen and set fires to tear down
the trees but the rubber tappers got
together and fought back
they organized in bocce's or
kids where they'd sit in front of trees
or block the path to the rubber reserves
to prevent loggers and bulldozers from
coming through Chico an Raimundo or both
on the front lines pathway formication
taken control brah hetaera o spoonski
Tahoe yes we'll settle this matter under
identical Sugoi hunter all this male
heir is Juan de Lucia Cebu I hate you
who party a scream finish yah
Lea I prefer introduce madam in
protecting the rubber tappers way of
life was at the heart of the struggle
led by Chico but over the years it
turned into a much bigger fight for
survival the government backed by
international organizations built roads
in the Amazon which brought
deforestation to different corners of
the rainforest as a result by 1987
nearly 300,000 square kilometers of the
rainforest had been torn down the fight
to prevent deforestation extended
throughout the Amazon and Chico became
its spokesperson on a global stage
[Applause]
I'm a hernia poor soils mitotic gooses
be large to the moon together we can
preserve the forest and make it
productive securing this immense
treasure for the future of all our
children began to pay attention every
day it involves the destruction of one
of Earth's greatest natural resources
the Amazon rainforest the rainforest is
unique in all the world once it is gone
it is gone forever
international organizations withdrew
tens of millions of dollars from the
development of the Amazon a small
extraction reserve was created for
rubber stoppers in Accra in 1988 the
first of its kind in Brazil the land
would be owned by the state but rubber
stoppers like Raimundo would have the
right to live and work on it look as if
he feared L am an ice-cold Fed one well
no I noticed him with the reserve would
keep everyone else out especially cattle
ranchers making this entire reserve
legally protected from deforestation but
in 1988 protecting the rainforest came
at a deadly cost 89 environmental
activists were killed that year alone
I've already escaped six attempts on my
life from the enemy though I have a
moral commitment to myself I cannot
abandon the struggle even if one day I
should be struck by an assassin's bullet
cattle ranchers looking to expand their
business in the Amazon saw Chico as a
threat he was given armed guards for
protection but just days after his 44th
birthday he was shot in his backyard his
killers were cattle ranchers a father
and a son whose land had just become a
protected area
Yasu revolted the trees or the mother
God when 82nd division two meter meter
distance who ships affirmative a
defendant who generated Acadia gelatin
which starred Oneg Shinagawa DHEC
necessity rate who generated sa as a
sonata form without public debate very
food she goes death pushed changes
forward in the Amazon a larger she co
Mendes extractive reserve was created in
1990 today it is still the biggest in
the Amazon and has protected more than 2
million acres of rainforest from a lot
of the deforestation that surrounds it
it's home to about ten thousand people
who can freely maintain their traditions
and livelihoods since she goes death all
these extractive reserves have been
created there are more than a hundred
spread throughout the Amazon but the
fight isn't over Brazil's current
government has pushed for more economic
development in the Amazon while
downplaying she costs they've also
scaled back efforts to preserve the
Amazon leaving protected areas at risk
all over again nearly half of the
deforestation is taking place in
protected areas including the Chicot
Mendes reserve where ranchers are
reportedly persuading rubber stoppers to
clear their land for money selling gear
sico zv delicacies air path da luta OS
town seed ando
a pratical the Jews Mata patria God but
some like Ramon the Sun are committed to
keeping Chico's legacy alive Maya say
pollutant Richie protégée is the keikyu
spice Quincy the McMaster spice no
premiere momento de pensar Catawba
defendant we sitting here we are for ESS
my deposit see the Kentucky taha's intra
balloon diffuser Damas only doing hi
thanks for watching the second episode
of Atlas and the Amazons miniseries I
want to take a quick second to thank the
filmmakers who films Chico Mendes and
the Amazon in the 80s that footage was
crucial in allowing us to tell Chico
story and the role he played in trying
to protect the Amazon we are very
grateful to them in the next episode we
look at the struggle between indigenous
people trying to protect their land and
the president threatening to take their
rights away make sure to come back and
watch the third and final episode of
outlets in the Amazons miniseries thanks
again for watching and see you next time